being threatened because of increased
spending they come from all over the
world but they're all pursuing the same
goal
these doctors teachers researchers and
administrators want to improve health
care for the people back home
they're at heidelberg university taking
part in a year-long master's program in
international health
one of the things the graduate students
learn is that to solve healthcare
problems in their own countries they
first need to understand how to organize
and finance concrete projects
at this meeting they're presenting their
thesis topics
i work with indigenous communities
in peru in the amazon and latin america
we have people working with disasters in
asia we have people working with
maternal health in africa so you get to
learn a little bit but all around the
world and you get to
understand success stories and maybe use
that in your own in your own country so
that's just invaluable
to ensure that what their students learn
will have an impact on the ground the
institute in heidelberg works together
with governments health authorities and
researchers from many nations
have examined the medical care that
expectant mothers and newborns receive
in kenya from there
so you see the way they are sharing
their precisely and examines the mother
one big problem there is the lack of
nurses in state-run hospitals
because they face long hours under
difficult conditions at home many
trained nurses choose to emigrate
instead there's so many patients that
come you see here we have three mothers
sharing a bed um this is the common
situation in a public health facility uh
this is a postnatal award when the
mother delivers each has their own baby
on the same bed so these are three
mothers with three babies on one bed
three patients and three babies sharing
one bedroom yes
sandra gavaut has looked at mortality
and life-threatening complications among
mothers and babies in three kenyan
hospitals
her results show that the number of
deaths that occur there every year could
be reduced with simple measures like an
emergency generator
a steady power supply can save lives
traffic accidents when you have a woman
who is hiv positive and who is giving
birth and you have no light and this
woman she has some some sutures to be
made you need to suture the woman you
don't have light how are you suturing
and most of the times you don't have
gloves so the doctors and the midwives
they are working with the patients that
are bleeding etc that have wounds
you need to stitch the wounds you don't
have gloves you don't have light so what
they do is they need new they use their
smartphones their phones to put light
with the phone that they are able to do
their work
a workshop held for program graduates is
focusing on neglected tropical diseases
this participant set up a hospital for
the poor in myanmar
now the group is looking at concepts
aimed at a specific problem what are the
best ways to combat parasitic worm
infestations in the region
how should health authorities be
involved where will the money come from
their studies are over but their joint
efforts to improve health care all over
the world continue
i've relented myself to